hi
everyone thank you so much for joining
us today i'm madison mills a journalist
at bloomberg news
and today we are talking about masks and
masculinity
men are more likely to get coven 19 but
they're also less likely to
wear masks and that's according to a new
study by valerio capraro who's joining
us today
we're also joined by liz planck an
author and
feminist icon who is talk with us
about men and masculinity um thank you
both so much for making the time we're
so lucky to have both of you here
uh and i also want to remind our
audience that uh if you're watching and
you have any questions that we're not
covering
this is a conversation for all of us so
please comment with any of your
questions
uh that we're not hitting and we will be
reading your comments and get to as many
as we can
but valerio i'd love to start with you
can you just give
our audience an overview of your
findings
uh yes absolutely first of all thank you
a lot madison for the invitation
and and sorry for my italian accent
so in this study we we collected that in
the u.s
from two uh 2500 people
um and we looked at intentions to wear a
face mask in three different scenarios
every time uh when engaged in physical
activities essential physical activities
and when around people outside
from their household and as a first
result we found that men
are less likely than women to intend to
report that they intend to wear face
covering
um but then in the second part of the
study we also try to
look at the reasons why there is this
gender difference
and we found some interesting results we
asked people whether they agree or
disagree with some statements
and the statements were wearing a face
covering
is not cool wearing a face covering is
shameful
and wearing a face covering is a sign of
weakness
and we found that men more than women
agree with these statements
so apparently it seems that part of the
reasons
why men less than women intend to wear a
face
mask is because they think is not uh
it's a sign of weakness and
and this was one result another result
that we found
interesting is that a men
more than women think that they will be
unaffected by the covet 19
and this also explains why uh less than
women intend to wear this covering and
if you think about this it's a bit
ironic if i can say this word because
actually from statistics we know that
men
are more likely than women to get
probably 19 and to die of government
absolutely and liz can you tell us your
thoughts on that and
your some of your research on men and
and masculinity and why mask wearing um
might
make them feel weak or not cool as
valerio mentioned
yeah i mean i uh wrote a book called for
the love of men
um a vision for mindful masculinity that
came out in september
of 2019 and i uh intentionally
started that book writing that our
current
version or current definition of
masculinity was the greatest threat to
humankind
and i got a lot of uh pushback for that
i got some praise you know some people
were like yeah
uh but a lot of people were like that's
a little much like you are exaggerating
um
and i obviously spent 376 i think pages
of the book
trying to defend um and and prove
that thesis through a wide variety of
studies
um that uh amazing academics like uh
valerio have
been doing on this topic and in in so
many different
uh industries and so many you know it
goes beyond health and it goes into
so many other uh spheres of our of our
lives and men's lives um
but what i found is that um this
thesis has become so much more
relevant and and unfortunately true
um in the era of you know this global
pandemic that we've been
uh all going through over over the last
few months so
um i was really excited and i told
valerio when we were in the green room
how excited i was that he conducted the
study i think it's extremely important
that we do study masculinity
um as a person who i was a woman studies
major
was a gender policy i i you know i did a
masters and graduate degree
in that field and um ended up realizing
that i'd never
really had a class about masculinity and
never really been assigned a book about
masculinity
um and and and how um you know
unfortunate that is not just for i think
the study of gender and
you know realizing that everyone has a
gender and that in the same way that
women are affected by
what they see on tv the roles that are
available to them in society
the same thing happens for men and boys
men and boys become
who we think they be men and boys become
who they think they're supposed to be
and so we're seeing this play out in
terms of the coronavirus
in terms of you know and it's really
unfortunate because
um it is we still we see play with the
coronavirus right
as valero stated more likely to die from
the coronavirus
more likely not to wear protection and
to
uh take the necessary precautions not to
die
so women who are yeah less likely to die
are more likely to to
to basically um do the right thing we
see that in
in the book as a lifeguard i remember
being in a lifeguard class uh in in one
of the trainings
and you know casually it was brought up
that you know
80 percent of drowning victims are male
and i remember just kind of pausing in
my tracks and raising my hand and being
like
wait what like why why um
our men just wore swimmers like is there
something in their genitalia that like
drags them down like what is going on
here um so it's not right a biological
there's no biological difference between
the swimming abilities of male and and
or like men and women
women have equal swimming abilities men
are far more likely not to wear
life jackets men are far more likely to
go on a boat
or to engage in aquatic activities when
they're under the influence of drugs or
alcohol
so they're more right they think that
they're less likely to end up in an
accident and therefore will take more
risks
so that's just one of the examples men
are less likely to wear sunscreen
more likely to die from skin cancer
despite having the same skin as women
um there there are so many different uh
you know
areas uh of of of especially men's
health that i think need this
conversation
and i'm you know disheartened by the
data that valerio and many other
um you know researchers have found but i
also hope that this can be a point of
you know rethinking like wow this is
what it means to be a man
like being a man means like i it is not
cool
to live like it is not is like gay
right like and gain a homophobic right
we know that that is tied to
you know our definition of masculinity
that that that it is like
gay to live you know so let's wow like
let's talk about that
and and and i hope that that this is
what this moment can can
can lead to absolutely and both of you
mentioned this idea of
sort of a lack of risk aversion among
men
um valerio your study touched on that a
lot this idea that it's not just that
men maybe don't want to wear a mask
because of the way it makes them
perceived but also that they
believe that they're more impervious to
the virus
uh and both of you mentioned in the
green room this idea that um
previous pandemics have have had these
risk aversion
issues come up so i'm wondering if you
can compare what's happening now to
other global health emergencies and how
men have handled those experiences as
well
uh yeah okay at least first of all let
me tell you that
you touched the great point and
um about risk aversion um
i i know quite well the point of view of
economists and social scientists and
um and it is well known that men tend to
be more
risk seeking than women uh it
comes out every time you do an
experiment even with small games
and small economic um consequences
but of course we see this uh every time
uh
in real life on youtube uh there are a
lot of these videos of men
doing super weird things and you know
about jackass
do you know the show jackass is a
do you know that show it was just a show
where men it went on for several seasons
in early 2000 and men just did
the work like the most dangerous things
in the world anyway keep going
yeah yeah that's right that's right i
think i saw something
but yeah so it's totally true and it's
it's dangerous also for other people
because for example
if you are not risk aware so you don't
wear this covering because
you under uh state the probability
that uh you get copied 19 or you don't
practice social distancing of
if we want to talk about other pandemics
maybe you don't wear you don't use a
condom during a sexual intercourse so
you can have all these problems
that clearly promote the spread of the
virus whatever that is
um yes there is this huge problem that
men are less risk averse than women
and but one question is why why are
men more risk-taking than women
i don't know at least if you have reason
about this i'm
really looking forward to hear your
perspective
well oh sorry were you done or were you
going to go into
yes i i'm done my question that i don't
know
uh very well how to answer is why are
men
more risk working than women is there a
reason maybe evolutionary or
partnership i don't know yeah so i mean
from the research that so i talk a lot
about risk in the book and is it is
actually one of the most
interesting parts of the research that i
came across
which was yes men are far more take far
more risk than women
overall so many examples of that in our
society right
um but there's actually something called
the like so
there's researchers that actually looked
into the data and parsed out
the the race of men who are averse their
uh documented status so whether they're
immigrant
at the what you know the sort of male
risk uh you know effect was actually a
white male risk effect so
white men are take so many more risks
than black men than uh you know
immigrant men uh than latino men than
indigenous men
that it kind of skews the entire gender
um and and actually makes us think that
all of all men you know regardless of
who they are how they identify
in the world take more risks than women
and and and so what we find
what we find is that yeah it is and
and you know it it basically it
intersects with
privilege right and and being you know
white versus black or brown in american
society
you know as we know and we as we've seen
recently and you know having
well-documented data for is a very
different experience in the world right
um and and and and so i
that to me is really interesting right
and
risk as you said is subjective
right how you know the amount of risk
that i weigh
that i could get the coronavirus is
subjective to me
and the amount of risk that you weigh
every day thinking about should i wash
my hands should i go see this person
should i
be in this car should i stay at home
like your way
it it's subjective and i think that when
we raise men in a society in a certain
way
um with a lot of privilege right with a
lot of
you know unfortunately sometimes
entitlement it makes them think that
they are
more invincible than they actually are
right or that they are entitled to doing
certain things
in in society and other people wear
masks but i don't have to wear a mask
and and so that actually puts them in
danger and it puts other people
in danger too um and so yeah i think
risk is
is a really fascinating thing and the
last thing i'll say just is my favorite
study about risk that sort of
exemplifies how it's all subjective
um when they asked white
men particularly about their risk
like white men basically are more risk
averse
when depending on what you ask them
right so in one particular study
they ask them are you risk-averse you
know when it comes to
taxing the rich taxing corporations more
heavily
uh more environmental uh guidelines
right
when it came to those things in which
white men are
going to be more affected by those laws
right if we tax you know
the one percent a lot of those people
um are white men uh in american society
i'm sure in italy it would
you know similarly be the same um the
same goes with
big environmental changes right that you
know those are things
that women that people of color
um there's a lot less risk for them
there's much more of a reward for them
and so again even the way that we talk
i'm so getting away from the coronavis
and i'm so sorry
but the way that we talk about risk and
what is a risk is
is also through often the lens of a of a
white man right
um so it's it's super it's a super
fascinating topic um
and then there's also testosterone right
which is a you know
you know men produce more testosterone
that's just like a you know biological
fact
and testosterone makes you more
competitive and makes you want to
um basically have more status but how we
define that status
right what is a a man that's on top of
the hierarchy versus a man that's below
the hierarchy
is what matters so if we have a
president for example
that says being a man on top of the
hierarchy is not wearing a mask
doing you know taking risks by you know
putting
milk thousands of people inside of
stadium and
uh you know going to as my the vice
president and pence
went to you know acquire where all these
people are singing without masking near
each other
that's what being the man the like
that's the man you know
um then that is rewarded and that is
what men will seek to do
that's where you get the it's not cool
right what is cool
valerio how do you measure what is cool
it's a completely subjective
you know assessment and so we have to
change what's cool right we need
different social norms
and we need to raise boys to decide
what's cool for them
not what's cool you know you know by the
society standards
which you know ultimately endangers them
when they
do what's cool absolutely
go ahead valerio yeah what are your
thoughts on that ah that's a good point
liz
um just just would like to add
uh something about uh gender differences
in testosterone because they highlight
the fact that there are also some
gender differences that are biological
yeah and
probably i think you agree with me that
these are partly due to
to the asymmetry on the cost of
reproductions
or the production very costly for women
but
very little costly for men so the men
in the market uh in the meeting market
is called this way
uh women are the precious resource
that men has to compete for and it
brings competition among men
uh high but
but i totally agree with your point that
then what is rewarded
is the key point so if we manage to
change the society
in such a way that what is rewarded is
something that is good for the society
for women in particular but also for men
for the society at large
that would be a revolution yes
social masculinity right and and when
you think about it women so
this is one of also my favorite data
points it has nothing it kind of has to
do with this
narcissism right we know 80 or something
like that right of narcissists are our
men
why is that is there again is there
something genetic and i went digging i
was really curious i was like oh there
must be something in the brain
and then whatever there's nothing
biological basically there's
the same amount of of of narcissists
that are born that are female and
and they're male like it's pretty much
like equal but it's not rewarded
for women to not have empathy and to not
show empathy it is not rewarded for
women to be selfish right women have to
actually
show a lot of selflessness um women have
to people right like there's all
you know women coming in and being
extremely confident is seen as arrogant
it doesn't get as rewarded and when we
think about what gets rewarded for men
it comes back to that status seeking
right the the coolest guy in the
in the room is the guy without the mask
is the guy who's extremely confident the
guy who might not have empathy
who's you know measuring you know sort
of has a
a way of going about things that doesn't
necessarily take others into
consideration
you know those are the men that we value
and so women are actually
you know there's a lot of women
narcissists basically lose that
like lose that um personality disorder
or it becomes a lot less you know
visible
and and so what could it look like you
know if we
didn't reward that with men or if again
we rewarded empathy and rewarded
the same kinds of things that we reward
with women with men or just that we let
everyone be who they want to be
you know like uh that that we wouldn't
have a certain
amount of rules or you know set
arbitrary norms
for one gender and then and in a
complete other set for the other based
on you know nothing
um so anyway sorry i keep getting off
track because i'm excited
to have valeria in the room oh no but
that's great
with everything you said and this study
you just mentioned
it's super fascinating i didn't know
about it it's crazy
yeah wild and liz
both of you are bringing up such
impeccable points um but liz you
mentioned
intersectional identities right and the
importance of
saying that you know we're talking about
white men when we're talking about
a lot of these things um valerio i'm
wondering if you can talk through
uh some demographic differences you
might have seen
in your study and how mask aversion
might differ between folks of different
races
uh yeah actually to be honest in terms
of
race we found very little um
i i must say that our sample is a bit
skewed towards
uh the whites so we have whites are over
represented
but we still have about 30 percent of
asians and blacks and also
multi-racials but we
didn't see major differences in terms of
race
you know what's interesting if i can add
um you know
that might also be because of social
reasons right so black men in america
um there's well documented instances in
this particular virus
or this particular pandemic where black
men who were wearing masks
were thrown out of stores for wearing
ads right
or even coming into a store wearing a
mask you know they were harassed
there was one guy who was like a up i
think he was working at walmart
you know putting like something in a
truck like doing you know changes in the
back and
he was you know stopped by the police
because and again he was wearing a mask
and they're like
what are you doing what are you stealing
something you know um
so there there's real um you know racial
biases
uh obviously they operate in american
society when it comes to men and
and you know face coverings and so what
you know your data didn't show a
difference and and that might be part of
it that black men
are way are weighing it in their heads
they're like well i know i should be
wearing this mask but like
am i going to get stopped by the cops
for being at walmart and you know
like just doing my job um and so that
might be
you know playing into it and also we've
seen um
the police do far more stops for in in
terms of violations
of social distancing for black and brown
communities um than
than than white people so we've just
seen more you know
sort of of a policing literally um
that might also play into that so you
know that that's
something we should you know should
remember as well
amazing pointless absolutely valerio did
you have a response to that
uh no i i totally agree with the point
uh unfortunately i wear that i cannot
answer this point uh
but yes i agree that can be can be like
this
absolutely can i ask valerio a question
too
yeah curious like what what
if you could do us like a follow-up
research
um and maybe you are on this topic what
would it be like or or had
has it made you think about other you
know things you want to study in terms
of health and masculinity
okay one thing i wanted to do and we
also have some partial results is
uh how can we convince people to
mask through appeals or messages that
can be displayed
on posters or screens
or or voiced on the street
and we have some results um
but okay one thing that we know it works
quite well
is to tell people that the coronavirus
is a threat
to their community rather than a threat
in general
so people react to the community uh
but in this case we didn't not find any
gender difference
so that this message increases
intentions towards
a face mask both for men and for women
and another result which we found is
to um make
to prime people to focus on their
reasoning so
it's very simple we tell people uh rely
on your reasoning
instead of relying on emotion and we see
that this simple
message make people more likely to
intend to wear this mask
or while if if we tell them uh to rely
on
on emotions they become less likely to
wear a mask
right yeah and but also in this case we
found no gender differences
so the effect is the same for men and
for women
we wanted to find something specific for
men
but so far we didn't manage to to find
any
anything but we'll continue digging
well isn't did your research find that
when mass were mandatory there
the gender you know difference
disappeared which i thought was
probably the most important thing right
so it comes back to the research on
uh paternity leave for example you know
denmark
a bunch of different countries tried to
do a bunch of different campaigns to
like
be like it's manly to take paternity
leave not really changing the needle
when they were like if you don't take it
you lose it
right the daddy leave you know sort of
famous uh
law that was passed in uh or policy that
was proposed in
in denmark that led to far more men
taking paternity leave
was just saying like that's what you got
to do that's what like the norm is
right you're setting a norm and you're
setting a default and then people have
to default out of it
um so i thought that was like that that
was just fascinating and
you know it more broadly uh you know
reinforced i think with the trend that
we're seeing that in countries
that were led by women some countries
that were led by women
uh slovakia new zealand right uh germany
we saw
women in those countries put on face
coverings very early
uh and and set the norm that that was
you know
the way that we were gonna do things and
that sets the norm for the entire you
know country basically and
and that they were able to eradicate the
virus much more quickly so it kind of
points to the need
you know not just in our society and in
the social norms but like
you know for that to trickle up or to
trickle down from you know having
diverse leadership
in countries and having women and men
inside the room
to set laws and policies and and
and you know prove that women can be
leaders too and really good leaders
uh sometimes better leaders um
so you know in in this particular you
know
healthcare of a health pandemic but in
other you know
other emergencies too
absolutely liz and you you bring up a
great point that we're getting a lot of
audience questions about which is
solutions
right we all want this uh pandemic to
come to an end um our audience is asking
what are some ways that we can change
the stigmas around masks and encourage
more people to wear them
valerio
okay so as i said we tried uh making
people to rely on their reasoning
and the idea was to make less
salient some negative emotions that
might come out though when thinking
about wearing a mask
and as i said before it worked but it
worked
for both genders which is good of course
because
there are also some women who don't wear
the mask
um so this worked but of course
it didn't work completely and
and we would like to find something that
works for men
specifically but didn't um
we were not able to do this yet and as
lis
was saying uh that's a very good point
um
simply making a mandatory tool but if
it's covering work so
in our data we found uh
that in counties where wearing a face
covering is mandatory
uh of course everybody is more likely to
intend to wear this covering but the
more interesting thing is that gender
difference is almost disappeared
so um making mandatory to worth
discovering affects
men more than women but only and this is
very interesting i think
uh this works only for intentions not
for emotions
men still think that wearing a face
covering
is not cool it's a sign of weakness
and it's shameful uh but they wear it
because
it's mandarin
that's fascinating yeah i mean i i
i have to yeah agree with everything
that you just said um
i think that we you know it's like seat
belts
like men men at one point were yeah far
less like i think they still are less
likely to wear seat belts but
generally everyone wears a seat belt and
we had the same debate
like i mean not the same but like a very
similar like some people were really
mad when seat belts became mandatory um
but we just like we're like you wear a
seat belt
and it's like the thing you just do when
you get in your car you wear your
seatbelt
when you leave your house you take your
keys and you take your mask that's it
that's just what we do now um and so to
me
it just speaks to the incredible
urgency of leadership in in
this country and in you know every other
country around the globe
of leaders modeling good
behavior and leaders modeling the very
behavior
um that that is absolutely necessary
to combat this virus and you know
i i can't you know i could go on and on
about
how how um just
gobsmacking it it is to see the leader
of this country go go out without a mask
and
tell reporters not to wear masks and ask
people who have come on a panel to speak
to take off their masks um
to hold rallies uh where people are not
wearing masks it's it's just
um i i i think the most irresponsible
thing we can do right now and
and and that's the model right like this
is the most powerful person
in the world this is the most powerful
person in this country and this is what
they're doing and so
um yeah i think like the manly mask
stuff
like the gi joe mask like sure whatever
like put whatever you want on it um
i don't care uh you know i i i
i wear pink masks cause i like pink if
you like blue and beers and
baseball bats like wear that that's cool
like express yourself
um just wear wear your dang mask um
you know that's just pretty simple
that's just that's just what we do now
i also saw if i can share i've seen some
people so i was walking down a park and
there were two guys walking without
masks and i saw a guy actually
run behind run like kind of like come
behind them
and then run away and start screaming
like like basically like a horror like
oh my god like i'm so afraid of you
you're not wearing a mask and he just
ran and like screamed and i was like oh
that's pretty funny
um so i think people can like you know
in their daily lives kind of
um use humor and and and
and different ways to re enforce this
message um i mean i
will be honest right now i'm
experiencing uh covet symptoms
uh since friday and when i've been had
to go out you know i've been wearing a
mask and i've been very you know careful
and i've knocked on out
mostly um but i it's made me think
differently i'm like wow like
if people and i was there's a two-person
role
in the elevator in this building that
i'm that i'm in and
um i've seen people kind of just be like
uh whatever coming in like no i have
symptoms like don't come in and you know
we have to assume that every person has
it
right and like those things need to be
drilled in
no matter what your gender is um so that
we we all fight we all can fight this
absolutely such a great point liz and
also of course we
hope that you are okay and safe and
healthy
me too i hope i can i just can't taste
anything that's the worst part
i'm like i love you know i'm having
breakfast and i'm just like i can't i
can't taste my peanut butter so i'm
excited i'm and if
this is covered i'm very lucky so um i
will keep you guys posted
thank you so much thank you and thank
you both for
for making time for this conversation um
during what i'm sure is a very busy
and hectic time for everyone so i'm very
thankful that you are here
um and for everyone yeah thank you so so
much
and for everyone watching uh please
follow quick take on all of your social
platforms
uh and again we just want to thank both
of you for making time
um you can follow valerio caprara and
liz planck on twitter at feminist abuse
uh and thank you both so much again for
your time thank you such an important
conversation
so great meeting you valerio so i'm
sorry
and keep going keep doing the great
research you're doing i'm excited to
follow
more of it yeah thanks thank you yeah
thank you both so much bye